[Music]
straight ahead all in law and crime
daily
an army veteran found dead in a
cornfield lured by a bogus pizza
delivery order it was that custody
battle it was retaliation
the inmate striking a deal then turning
around and implicating his ex-wife but
is he telling the truth he's gonna pay
for by spending the rest of his life in
prison could an entire case hinge on the
word of a child testifying about a fake
pizza order it would seem that father
and daughter
don't have their facts straight law on
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone i'm brian buckmart
along with terry austin we're breaking
down the trial of the state of ohio
versus erica stefanco on this special
edition of law and crime daily
prosecutors say army veteran ashley
biggs and her ex-boyfriend chad cobb
were in a custody battle over their
daughter in 2012. at the time biggs was
working as a pizza delivery driver
according to the state cobb and his then
wife erica stefanco used biggs's job to
lure her to a closed business with a
fake order then cobb killed her cobb
pled guilty and was sentenced to life
without parole he's agreed to testify
against defanco with no plea deal
prosecutors began the trial by showing
the jury different locations in the case
with the use of drone video they saw the
dominoes where the victim worked the
alleged crime scene and the cornfield
where the victim's body was found inside
her car
erica stefanko made that phone call that
lord ashley gave her death evidence and
testimony will show when she made that
phone call she used a fake name
it was approximately 11 42 at night
and she had ashley come to a business
that was closed captioning not
that
available
went to the area she was supposed to
that's when she was confronted by chad
cobb
that is when
the zip tie was placed that is when she
was beat that is where she was thrown in
her car
the defense argued the victim and her ex
were in a heated custody dispute over
their seven-year-old daughter and chad
cobb had all the motive to want biggs
dead
2017.
he's stewing in that prison
and now he's trying to get
out from under full responsibility
because he wants to drag somebody else
down to his level
he wants to get out of prison early
he wants his sentence shortened
ladies and gentlemen this is the kind of
person that you are going to try to
evaluate
someone
that
took
the mother of his daughter
ambushed her
beat her
and strangled her
and you are going to determine
how much truth
is in his statement
an issue of credibility there terry the
motive for murdering ashley biggs was a
child custody dispute why do you think
prosecutors say stefonko helped chad
cobb kill biggs
you know brian i think in this case it
was largely jealousy i think that
stefanko was jealous of ashley biggs
even though she was the ex-wife and i
think that's why she participated and it
was probably a little bit of pressure
from chad cobb i mean at the time we
know that they were married and so try
to try to pressure her and it was
premeditated and cruel they worked
together on how they were going to do
this so i definitely think that there is
motive here both for chad and for
stefanko
now to a key piece of evidence
prosecutors have against stefanko in
court the jury heard this recording chad
cobb's mother made of the defendant
allegedly confessing to her involvement
i'm not trying anybody i'm just
coming forward
i mean you told me face-to-face
[Applause]
and it wasn't because it was
forcing me to do it or like he had a gun
to my head it was because he said this
is your heart and this is what you're
going to do which is how it always we're
supposed to do
this recording saturn is safe for four
years before sydney cobb handed it over
as evidence after stefanko divorced her
son at trial she asked not to have her
face shown
but you felt that somehow erica was
responsible
yes
did you believe eric was completely
responsible for him being there or
partially responsible partially it took
two
what prompted you to record
erica
off and on
through the years we would have
issues if she
got upset about something
she would withhold the kids from us
it would be you know and until we can
sit down and talk the kids aren't going
to be able to come over
this happened several times
we had just come back from vacation
and she wanted to meet with us
with me to talk
and it was during this time where
chad was wanting the divorce
the tools situation
i decided i was just going to record
tired of always being called on the mat
and always having the kids withheld from
us
cobb isn't getting a plea deal to
testify but the defense asked his mother
if she still has something to gain with
stefanko behind bars
no like i stated we'd seen him
a few days prior
and they were getting ready to go on
vacation
was he acting erratically though
no
did he take the attitude
of
women should be
kept barefoot and pregnant down on the
farm no
still ahead on law and crime daily we
hear from chad cobb himself will it
confess killer story match up the direct
and cross-examination after the break
[Music]
welcome back an ohio man in the middle
of a deadly love triangle is pointing
the finger at his ex-wife for the
killing of his ex-girlfriend
chad cop pled guilty to murdering ashley
biggs a retired army veteran and pizza
delivery driver biggs was found dead in
her car in a cornfield cobb later
implicated erica stefanko who divorced
him after his arrest cobb says stefanko
placed a fake pizza order at domino's to
lure biggs to her death
i remember
her saying somebody else's name
i remember it was a a
jennifer or
katie and it was mick something
like like how you say mcdonald's i just
i don't remember what she said the last
name was
and i remember she ordered a pizza and i
remember it struck me as bizarre because
she ordered
a half pepperoni and mushroom pizza
after she made the phone call what did
you do
i was stole over by the tree
were the kids all still in the car when
she made the phone call
yes sir as far as you know did the kids
ever leave the car
no sir
cobb says he was outside next to a tree
when stefanko plays the fake pizza order
he says he watched as big's car pulled
to the wear they were waiting
with everything that was going on
looking back
she wasn't happy to
to see me that's for certain what did
you do
with
ashley's body
when
i had to leave i picked her up and put
her in the car
whose car
ashley's car
in the back seat
and when you put her in the back seat
did she have anything on her that
that was placed on
her that she didn't have on her when she
arrived
yes there was
a zip tie
how many
i only remember one
i remember one around her neck
erica stefano was on trial for the
murder of retired army veteran ashley
biggs under cross examination cobb says
he's not the killer
he was actually
in her car when
i drove it to our bridge in in the field
yes
yes sir was ashley already dead
yes sir
did you strangle her
i am not the one that strangled her sir
i see so now you plead guilty
and now you're saying that
you didn't kill her is that right
yes sir
you drove the car to the far end of a
cornfield correct
yes sir
that cornfield was pretty far off the
road true
yes sir i don't know
how
uh how far but a decent walk
the lawn cry network spoke to cobb's
former attorney and asked him if he
could explain why cobb denied strangling
biggs with a zip tie
well no it's the short answer
you know the physical evidence was
pretty overwhelming
i was surprised by that testimony i
really don't want to speculate on on
chad's motives
i can tell you based on what i had seen
at the trial
that it was clear that there was some
difficulties between chad and his
ex-wife i don't think it's any secret
and it came out
that erica ended up marrying chad's best
friend i don't think it's any secret it
came out during the trial that there was
some custody issues between
cindy cobb chad's mom and his parents
and her ability to see and have access
to her grandkids
um i i think that certainly didn't
help
erica's motive to
not get detected and i think that had
some play in
chad ultimately coming forward and
agreeing to testify
i mean terry let's address the elephant
in the room first cobb pled guilty to
murdering ashley biggs now he didn't do
it while on the stand what's what's
going on here
you know we don't see this often brian
but it's not unprecedented sometimes
defendants will change their story he
may have pled guilty in the beginning
when he was actually married to erica
stefanco but then once the divorce
proceeding started he felt as though he
had to turn against her and then he
decided he did not do the crime but that
in fact defanco did the crime so he's
now trying to save himself and he's
trying to blame someone else and i think
because his situation
with his wife changed he's now changing
the whole story as it relates to the
murder of ashley biggs now how does that
play out though terry because the
stories don't seem to be lining up
perfectly based on different pizza
orders or confessions by different
people who did or didn't strangle
the victim in this case how does that
leave the case
actually i think it leaves some doubt so
it might actually work to stefanko's
benefit if in fact there are all of
these conflicting stories the jury is
going to be a bit confused about what
the real truth is a confused jury is
definitely a benefit to the defense and
not the prosecution got to continue to
watch his trial as it progresses to see
how it plays out though thank you coming
up on law and crime daily the fake pizza
delivery murder but who placed the order
hear from a teen who says she knows the
real killer ahead
[Music]
back now to the fake pizza order murder
case the defendant's seven-year-old
step-daughter allegedly was in the car
at the time it was placed she's 15 now
so we're not going to show her face but
she says she remembers hearing the
defendant order a pizza
i can remember
her
and i remember hearing it but not seeing
it
and
i know she ordered a pizza
i don't remember what she said that was
on it
and i can remember that she did not use
her name
do you remember what name she did use
do you know where you were when you
heard this phone call being made
in the back of a car
do you know why
your dad is in prison
yes
why is that
because he did some not so nice things
is it your understanding
that he did some
not so nice things
to your mother
yes do you still love your dad
yes i do
would you like to see him get out of
prison soon
yeah he's right yes he's my dad do you
think by being here that you're helping
your dad get out of prison
no this isn't his case
now terry seven at the time 15 now she
testified that's almost double her age
at the time how credible was the
testimony of the daughter
i think it was fairly credible that's
really something the jury is going to
have to look at very carefully if she
was seven at the time
we have to wonder whether or not she was
old enough to actually have her own
memories and one thing that the jury is
going to have to figure out too is
whether or not she is doing this to help
her father one would have to think that
she is yeah now father on trial for
murder mother dead where does this leave
the daughter now
you know brian we know that he's
currently with the grandfather we know
this is the chad cubs mom but in the
future we don't know where she will
exactly be they could very well be
placed in custody with the ohio
department of child services she could
be placed with another relative you know
i think the ultimate goal here is to
have her adopted by a family member and
that family member could very well be
the grandmother
yeah of course while we're keeping an
eye on this case we hope the best for
this daughter and this young girl she's
only 15 years old and so hopefully the
state can provide her that help and that
wraparound service to ensure this
doesn't affect her as much as it
probably is thank you terry when we come
back which side will the jury believe is
an ohio woman guilty of murder or is
erica stefanko wrongly accused after all
these years the verdict after the break
the jury has found the defendant erica
stefanko guilty
of the offense of aggravated murder the
jury has found the defendant erica
stefanko not guilty of the offense of
aggravated murder the jury has found the
defendant erica stefanko not guilty of
the offense of kidnapping the jury has
found the defendant erica stefanko not
guilty of the offense of aggravated
robbery
after 15 hours of deliberations a jury
delivered a mixed verdict in the murder
of trial of an ohio woman accused of
helping to kill her husband's
ex-girlfriend
then it was up to the judge to decide
erica stefanko's fate she faced up to
life in prison without the possibility
of parole for the luring of a pizza
delivery driver to her death
army veteran ashley biggs was murdered
in 2012. her ex-boyfriend chad cobb pled
guilty then turned in his ex-wife erica
stefanco prosecutors say biggs and cobb
were in a custody battle over their
daughter at the time biggs was working
as a pizza delivery driver cobbs and
stefonko were convicted of using biggs's
job to lure her into a closed business
with a fake order then cobb killed her
and the children of the defendant and
the victim was in the back seat of the
car when this all went down
the night of the murder i can still
remember you using a fake name to order
the pizza to lure my mother into her
death trap
he had so much jealousy
of
so much jealousy of and hatred towards
my mom that not only did you run me and
my mother but also my dad
why is it that my dad bought airfare to
disney world but you were conspiring
behind his back to do this to my mom
we can never expose the monster you are
and the harm you caused me because in
your words we need to be on the same
page
or you would take my family away from me
even my siblings
and the defender herself spoke giving a
tearful statement to the court before
she was sentenced by the judge
your honor
if it is
healing
and helpful
to ashley's family
and friends
to grace
think of being as the monster if it is
helpful
for cindy uh
to exonerate her child for his own
actions
by putting the blame on me if that helps
these people
particularly people who are victims
i can accept that
i was most certainly
my worst self during my relationship
with chad
i have never
been
a hateful person
i would never have wanted
what happened
to ashley biggs
regardless
of what statements people think that
they heard on that tape
the state of ohio has elected to
sentence and move forward on sentencing
on the conviction of aggravated murder
prior to committing the offense the
defender had not been convicted of or
pleaded guilty to a criminal offense
prior to committing the offense the
offender had led a law-abiding life for
a significant number of years
the offense was committed under
circumstances not likely to reoccur
the offender shows genuine remorse for
the offense the court is issuing a life
sentence with parole eligibility after
30 years
terry was this the right sentence
after all the facts came into play
yeah you know brian i think having a
mixed sentence is probably the right
thing you know guilty on some counts not
guilty on other counts life in prison is
probably the right answer here by the
judge yes there were no priors but this
was a murder she was convicted of murder
and so i think killing the parent of
another person also is something that
should require a life sentence and do
you think stefanko's statements in any
way may have impacted the judge or the
family in this decision
you know brian most of the time the
judge has already made a
when they hear what the impact
statements are or hear what the
defendant has to say i think the fact
that stefanko did show some remorse
helps the family but i don't think as
far as the judge was concerned it
helped the final determination yeah
absolutely when it comes to the
sentencing i don't know if it moved any
the needle in any way shape or form but
thank you for that terry and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you